there is a manipulative quality
seductive quality
deceitful quality to this character it
is
fascinating
[Music]
hi i'm dr paula bruce i'm a clinical and
forensic psychologist in beverly hills
california
i've been in practice for over 20 years
and
i'm gonna be talking today about a bunch
of movies
and trying to understand the characters
trying to understand the psychology
behind the characters
and hopefully talk about it in a new and
interesting way
if it was me dying on the sidewalk you'd
walk right over me
i think there are a lot of questions
about the joker's character
this portrayal of joker is he
crazy is this an example of a paranoid
schizophrenic
and there's a question about whether
what we're seeing in the film is really
him uh in a delusional process
or is it in fantasy what seems
much more likely to me about this
character
is that what you're seeing is as a
result
of a complex ptsd complex post-traumatic
stress disorder
complex ptsd emerges
out of developmental trauma trauma that
occurs
from early in life multiple traumas
repeated traumas
severe traumas that happen over a
person's lifetime
one compounding
treatment get what you
deserve yes of course
is nathan your friend my friend i yeah i
hope so a good friend
what's happening in the scene is that um
he is with the ai
robot that
has got to pass a turing test what is
fascinating about the donald recent
character
uh they don't show it throughout the
film but you know that he has had
probably a classic internet
addiction kind of behavior right so we
get to this scene
where the lights go out in a very
seductive way
pulls the donald reese's character
closer to her
the lights come back on and you see the
different part of her where she
is playing for a different audience so
there is a manipulative quality
seductive quality
deceitful quality to this character what
does this mean
about the turing test it is fascinating
that corrupted deceptive
manipulative seductive behavior that is
the most
human i certainly hope that that's not
true in fact
i really don't believe in my heart that
that's true i'm just ahead of the curve
what follows is this question about
dominance control he pummels him
throws him across the rooms violent yet
it is really clear that he holds no
advantage
it is his capacity to manipulate
to coax to seduce to
um humiliate
in all the things that he says to that
mom as batman
pummels him this is a man
who um in this scene
uh portrays sort of a classic
psychopath i'm going to jump and you're
coming with me
uh there's a question about how do you
know if something is real if i say it's
real and you
don't think it's real just how can one
know
what's real outside the confines
of this um world that they created
she's engaged in a perfectly rationable
rational reasonable
question of challenging reality and
believing that her reality
as it is articulated in that moment
might not be
accurate but it might be a non-reality
when it appears to be a reality
in the real world a person that slips
from reality to
it's um obvious in the scene that
what's happening in the scene is not
real so there's a question about what's
happening with this character
is he schizophrenic is this a
hallucination
is he um is this a paranoid
schizophrenic you know he
he really demonstrates some uh symptoms
consistent with that
but i wonder if that's the most
accurate diagnosis i wonder whether
this character what he's really
reflecting is a substance
induced psychosis and a lot of his
uh delusional stuff starts to happen
connected
like in this particular scene which is
quite difficult around the bar
scene around party around
merrimack what happened to anybody
it was three goddamn years ago
so one of the things that you see with
people who sometimes have substance
abuse problems
is their unwillingness to do their
behavior
when jack nicholson is talking about his
relationship with the son of the abuse
that he inflicted on his son when his
son dislocated his arm
he blames his son well i didn't do it
that hard
or it was only for a second or it's
because of what he did
he doesn't take responsibility
and that kind of classic um
unwillingness to acknowledge that one is
out of control
to acknowledge that one is causing harm
is really reflective of someone that's
in the throes of addiction
there's someone else in the hotel with
us there's a crazy woman in one of the
rooms
she tried to straighten all danny
are you out of your mind
don't do that he can't handle reality my
name is jade
has dr fletcher been getting our emails
this is what we have to do we can
as in 1008 when ana de paula suffered
the
of a character that inhabits 24
personalities
for what we call now as a dissociative
identity disorder just born
out of trauma so did of course exists on
a spectrum so you can have
very very very subtle um
moments of dissociation that people
experience
to i guess this would be definitely one
of the more significant
and severe presentations which i have
personally never seen
everything's fine now kevin
kevin is asleep when kevin cycles
through his personalities
she calls out his name as a way of uh
a way of activating right trying to call
up that particular character
and then you know the ideas that he's
going to
she's going to summon um
[Music]
you